when a screenwriter finishes the
screenplay is there a checklist that
they should sort of mentally or
physically check off in terms of the
business aspects of getting the script
out there not just proofreading and
grammar and syntax all that but I'm
talking about in terms of you know what
are the next steps who should they be
sending things out should they make a
chart of who they sent it out to I think
it's a good idea to see you need to have
a checklist or a chart certainly sending
it out to a consultant or somebody who
professional in the in the industry is
is always very helpful because it gives
you an idea of from somebody who has
been in the industry a long time what is
it that might what are the little things
and some of the bigger things that might
keep it from moving ahead I think that
also if you if you have a I think one of
the things that bothers me is when I is
when I see that people really haven't
taken the time to proof I'm not kidding
you that's a major thing I have when I
was an executive I actually had cohorts
in my office who were also execs who if
they found more than three mistakes in
the first 20 pages they would not they
would stop reading and they've throw it
in the trash you just hate to say that
but that happens that really
honest-to-god that that does happen on
the other hand I'm always looking give
me a reason to say yes you know so make
sure that you're you know you know the
structure of your your screenplay is
such that right off the bat it catches
your attention that that we are that
you've got characters that are so
relatable that we're going to want to
see them and see them either succeed or
or to see the guy the antagonists fail
that's one of the one of the big things
that I say is a lot of times people will
pay more attention to the hero and the
unfortunate thing is they don't set up
the antagonists well enough that it
gives the hero enough enough enough
contrast and interest
that's a big thing that I see a lot and
sometimes in the things that I've read
is that they just the whoever he's up
against whether whether it doesn't have
to be a person it could be the elements
it's like a storm or something or or it
could just you know it could just be
himself but you don't see enough
contrast in what's going on and so I
think that's another big mistake that
that people make in that they they
should take a look at it and have
somebody read it and just say you know
and ask that question is my antagonist
strong enough yeah do you understand
what's at stake and do you feel that the
hero has has worked hard enough to
achieve that success what's the
difference though between getting
coverage and getting consultation okay
coverage a lot of people say okay yeah
I'm gonna get coverage on this so they
will send it out coverage is something
that we use in the studio just to see
just so that the executive will know
what is the story about because they
sometimes don't have time to read the
whole script it takes about an hour and
a half to read a script and with a
thousand scripts coming in every month
it's a lot of reading so that's why they
have story departments who do the
reading so coverage is just like a book
report it has a it tells you it has a
little log line in the front which is
one or two sentences that tells you the
the general idea of what the story's
about and then it's basically just
telling you the story just like a
regular book report this is what happens
and it usually is done in chronological
order and then it usually tells you a
little bit you know they'll be box
scores or something that will tell you
okay is this a big budget you know where
does it fall in the budget is that how
do you how would you grade it in terms
of do you think the dialogue was was
well-written do you think the care you
understood the characters and that
they're they they have a story worth
telling you know they don't have those
kind of little boxes and you mark them
off that usually says you know like
excellent good bad fare you know that
like that in poor and they just check
those off and then they
just write a little thing about I feel
that I feel that the character that the
hero is too weak and there's just not
enough interest in here you know for us
there's not enough at stake for us to
really root for him you know so they
might give a few things what a
consultation does is they not only read
your whole script they go through and
they usually tell you exactly what they
feel does not work they get into details
your dialogue is to on the news or we
you you mentioned this character in the
beginning but we don't know why do you
include this character if there's no
payoff at the end for the character or
they'll say gosh you know I I like your
hero but you know you're for some reason
I don't quite understand why your
dialogue doesn't match the personality
that you've given him that happens a lot
to where you know people people put
their own words into the character
rather than the characters words into
the dialogue and that happens a lot too
so that those are just some of the
things that you know that consultants
will find I think the good thing too
about having a consultant is they will
tell you you know if you like for right
now if you send in something that has to
do with zombies or it has to do with you
know dystopian ideas and some sometimes
they'll you know a consultant will say
you know look they they don't mind but
it has to have this and this and this
zombies are we've had too much too many
submissions on that they probably aren't
if their chances kind of go down if it's
about zombies I mean they will give you
hopefully some up-to-date information on
what they were they've gleaned from
reading the trade papers and and all
that so I that's what I do when I do a
consultation I will be very upfront
about what I feel works and doesn't work
about they're not just about the writing
but
about the script in general and how the
marketplace is now because I don't want
to ever lead them in the wrong direction
and I will be very upfront I'm not gonna
be like brutal in my I'm not I try not
to be brutal because nobody deserves
that but if somebody we recently had
somebody last year send me a script
about zombies and I had to be very
honest about it and I said you know this
would have been a good script for people
to consider three years ago
unfortunately I know for a fact that I
was recently at such-and-such you know
at the script fest and and I know that
several agents have said they do do not
want to see any more zombie scripts they
feel that that that they've just been
too many of them I mean you have to be
honest about it I don't want to build up
their hopes on that I've done things
also where I have said do you think you
can make a transition here where instead
of zombies maybe it has to do with
something that like that there's there
are people here who are actually aliens
who have come to earth or you know I
help them come to a way that they can
maybe change it so that the heart of the
story remains but the situation itself
like zombies or something can be changed
I mean it's it's different ways of being
in different consultations differ a lot
I try to do that if I can with mine and
I think a lot of my my colleagues do
that too where we try to find out what
we feel is the best of what they are
doing and letting them know what that is
and that this is this is what we liked
about it and then let them know this is
what could be a problem and also along
with it what whatever new information we
can give them such as you know this is
we think that zombies have had their run
we've been talking to you know we were
on panels and we've talked to agents and
producers and and this is what seems you
know this is not this is the and I
sometimes ye even put these are some of
the areas that they're looking at if
they happen to mention
anything you know like they're looking
for you know more action pieces or
whatever the whatever you know they are
looking for I I just try to give them a
little bit more additional information
about where they could take this project
or where they could themselves what they
want to start another project what area
they might want to start in
you